37 year drought what does the industry
do after the magic the pixie does of
American Pharoah Lee yeah I mean it's
pretty tough I'm after 37 years of not
having a Triple Crown and now having a
triple till 2050 - well you're not maybe
not till 2050 - but I don't think it's
gonna happen this year okay
well I think it's a wide-open field
there's a is a big favorite Nyquist he's
undefeated
he won seven four seven five one five
races is a two-year-old two times as a
three-year-old he won and he's by his
side by a horse named Uncle Mo now Uncle
Mo win in the 2011 Derby and finished
out of the money but he's about great
but he's been a great sigh but not for
this but for the distance we don't know
is his first crop of three-year-olds
this year right so we don't know both
the horses a Nyquist and outwork one out
of mile on an eighth but this is a mile
on a court it is unknown territory okay
Tom you know of course that there's a
surveillance horse right it's called
sudden breaking news I know the odds are
20 to 1 but you know this is us this is
you were talking about when you look at
the total numbers of people right
attending the Kentucky Derby a hundred
and fifty thousand last year are we
expecting even more people this year I
don't think there'll be more than 150
thousand last year they were they were
really you know there was it was great
because American Pharoah was the big
talk and this year it's wide open and we
don't know what's gonna happen but I
think you'll still get a good crowd yeah
how much Lee when you look at breeders
around the world I know this is probably
the most watch to 12 minutes horse
racing here in Europe we have the Irish
great breeders and then you also have
some of the middle eastern countries who
are the strongest horse breeders around
the world well in in the in in the
Middle East they have a lot of big
breeds as shag well stables they have a
breeding I'm not sure off the top of my
head of who's in you know the ranking of
the breed is but
with the pixie dust that we see there's
no nothing like that the trumpet and all
that and then how many horses will line
up at the gate
they'll be 20 horses 40 horses right
decides which jockey gets on which horse
well the trainer usually you know
corresponds with the he talks to the
owners and they decide on which jockey
is gonna rise so the jockeys know right
now which horse they're gonna get yeah
oh yeah yeah okay then within that if we
got a wide-open field paper as you say
the idea of the jockey making a
difference this year must be front and
center well yeah they're all great
jockeys I mean all 20 of them all so
that's not shocking yeah and some of
them have won the Kentucky Derby race
war like Gary Stevens who's the the the
jockey on the horse that I like number
17 more spirit and you know the they
were all Prime great riders Francine for
the Kentucky Derby this is what the pros
use this is the Daily Racing Form to me
it's in Greek but but Lee Davis is just
X look how its marked up I mean there is
a document worth millions I say billions
of dollars right now Francine jump in
here yeah Tom you know we talked about
asset return and what's amazing when you
look at these horses guys maybe Lee how
much are these horses worse and how much
can they expect to win I know in a year
they can win up to what 2 3 million how
much does it take to buy one of these
horses well sometimes as little as
10,000 15,000 if you get lucky in this
race there's a horse mow Haman they paid
2.2 million dollars for the loss which
doesn't give them us an advantage when
he's running he's just bred well and you
know sometimes that'll uh you know
sometimes that'll you know just give
okay the the the people that watch
thinking that that's the best 100 bucks
what do I do
okay this is it $100 I'm writing go I
need to win on number 17 more spirit Bob
Baffert is gonna try to make it two in a
row you won
american pharoah we trained american
pharoah lytia he's gonna come right back
he did that in 1997 in 1998 with Silva
Charmin Real Quiet
he's gonna try to do it again I want to
make a $1 trifecta box these are the
numbers 3 6 10 17 and 18 that's a $60
bet there it is you heard it here insert
gentlemen team Rotondo thank you so much